Kobolds
are monsters that feed on strong magical energy to increase their strength.
Despite their appearance, they are quite strong.
However, as expected from the Priestess of Laurel, that magic wall will last
long enough to take out the Kobolds. There may be
4 of them, or 1 of each person at the same time.  If you
fail to take down the kobolds, they will raise their regulations and call your friends. I can't believe you have
n't even bought a monster yet,
Hibiki. Don't worry, go.
I can't stand back. I don't have a magic wall. I
hesitated, so please
help me.
I'm the
hero who will end this war. Why should I
stop here? Let's
go! Hibiki
continues [Music] It's a good start for my first time.
Yo
I